Speaker 1: All right. One of the talking points
that has been repeated ad nauseum in the context
of the Joe Biden withdrawal from Afghanistan has
been Trump would have done it better. Trump would
have done it differently. Trump had a plan to do
it just perfectly tactically. Even if the strategy
of getting out was correct for both Trump and
Biden tactically, Trump would have executed this
better. We now have an interview that Donald
Trump did on Fox Business with Stuart Varney.
The interview was a complete and total softball
interview, and Donald Trump still managed to screw
it up and humiliate himself. He was actually
asked, would you have done it differently? And
he's a completely unable to articulate what it is
that he would have done differently. So let's just
jump right into the middle of the interview.
Then we'll go back and look at some other
parts of it. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 4: What should President Biden
say to the American people this afternoon
about what you think he might say,
but what do you think he should say?
Speaker 5: Right. He should say,
I'm sorry, because that's what he he
owes an apology. And we all remember
Speaker 1: Trump never apologized for anything,
anything, anything. But Biden should apologize
for doing the same thing Trump was going to do
Speaker 5: looking at his watch yesterday. I've
been to Dover many times when he kept looking at
his watch yesterday at Dover with the parents and
spouses of people that were killed and Marines and
the and the Navy sailor that was killed. And he's
looking at his watch like, get me the hell out
of here. I want to go home, get me out. I want
to go home. I mean, how many times did he look
at his watch when he did that yesterday? It was
it was a disgrace. I think the best thing he
can do is apologize to the American people
and apologize to the world. You know, we had
a lot of help in Afghanistan and we left and
everybody else had to live with us. But, you
know, the whole world deserves an apology.
He gave it he handed them a country, one of
the better now one of the best armed countries
anywhere in the world with the best equipment
in the world better than our soldiers have.
He handed them a country on a silver platter,
Speaker 1: OK, so unable to articulate absolutely
anything that he would have done
differently. And let's just zoom out
and look at more of this interview
and you'll see that it was all B.S.
Trump had no better plan.
Speaker 5: Very importantly,
we have been humiliated as a major player.
Our our allies aren't going to look at us
the same. You know, our allies took advantage
of us for years. And I let people know it and
I let them know it. And they started paying in
NATO, where they really took advantage of us
trading partners, took tremendous advantage. The
European nation, European Union was worse. The
European Union was as bad as China or almost
as bad as China in terms of us with trade.
And yet we protected them militarily.
Speaker 1: None of this is true, of course,
but I want to get to the Afghanistan stuff,
Speaker 5: NATO, which is largely the same
group of nations. I will say this.
They have lost tremendous respect
for the United States of America.
Speaker 1: And now the truth is the
opposite. The truth is that respect
for the United States of America,
but both from foreign leaders and foreign
citizens other than in Russia and I think
maybe Turkey, there was like one other Russians
love the Trump and there were like one or two
other countries. But global respect for the U.S.
was at his lowest in decades under Trump and it
is significantly recovered already. We have
data on this Pew Research Center and others.
Speaker 5: I was president. They
had unbelievable respect for us.
That's a lie. I lost tremendous respect for our
country like this beyond anything imaginable.
Speaker 4: Angela Merkel, chancellor of Germany,
is talking about continuing an operation to get
people out, even though America has now left.
Speaker 1: Now, remember Joe Biden said.
We have an open ended commitment to getting
people who want to leave Afghanistan out.
He said it yesterday. He said we're down to one
or 200 people. There is no set date. Some of these
are dual citizens who may want to be there right
now at any time that they want to get out. We will
help get them out. These are these are all lies.
Speaker 4: They are continuing to get people out
or trying to at least all. Well, should we?
Speaker 5:
Well, we should. We shouldn't. We can't leave
Americans behind. How do we know which were not
a reason to do that? How do we do it? I spoke I
spoke with Abdul, the leader of the Taliban, on
a number of occasions.
Speaker 1: Sometimes he'll refer
to the leader as Muhammad generically.
Now he's saying Abdul, it's not really
clear. Trump knows who he's talking about.
Speaker 5: And it was very tough conversations.
And I said, we know where you live. We know
everything about you. We know about your people,
your top people. Some of them let out because of
Bergdahl, who was a traitor. Would they let them
out? They gave five people, three of whom became
top people in the Taliban, probably were before.
But I had a very, very tough conversation with
him. They weren't going to do anything until Biden
came in. Once Biden came in, it was different.
Speaker 1: Now, understand that Trump is
making the case everything is different
merely because Joe Biden is president.
Just by virtue of Trump being president,
everything would have gone differently.
The reality is he is not actually articulating
the reasons why anything would have been
different if Donald Trump had handled this. So
no plans to avoid the problems that Biden had.
He would have had them. The same thing
would have happened. Except what would the
difference have been if it had been Trump,
Trump would not have taken responsibility,
whereas yesterday Joe Biden said, I take
responsibility for what happened in getting out.
But getting out was still the correct decision.
An incredible softball interview handed to Trump
on a silver platter, the likes of which he's been
using since birth. Right, metaphorically. And he
still can't actually articulate why he would have
handled this any better than Joe Biden will have
more clips from this interview on our Instagram,
where you can follow us at David Pakman show.